bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur un
ferté france c'est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui assez de recul sur le kobe
19 pour en arriver à des affirmations
notamment concernant l'éventuel nous
contagiosité des asymptomatiques
oh non certainement pas on n'a pas assez
de recul et comme vous l'avez
parfaitement bien indiqués avec une très
jolie bibliographie dans l'exposé
antérieure et il ya des études qui
contredit tous tout au moins qui ne vont
pas dans le même sens en fait la vérité
elle est sans doute au milieu c'est à
dire que il faut remettre les études
dans le contexte dans lequel elles sont
faits c'est-à-dire y fier avec une
circulation virale qui a été extrêmement
faible
ça c'est un point et c'est une réussite
du confinement à la chinoise entre
parenthèses je suis pas sûr qu'on
accepte la même chose en france avec des
policiers qui viennent nous allons voir
si vous êtes déjà acheté vous feront
signer et des drones qui surveille vos
allées mais bon ceux de mise à plat il
est il est clair que quand il y a une
faible circulation du virus
les patients asymptomatiques qui
essaient connus ont une charge virale
dans l'ensemble moins élevé que les
autres sont plus faiblement contagieux
sa cdc
je dirais c'est pas une surprise ce qui
importe
je pense ça c'est pour une vie normale
ce qui importe en quand on est en phase
épidémique
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe quand il y
a beaucoup de circulation virale et
qu'est ce qu'on peut en déduire pour une
circulation virale extrêmement
importante et donc la laitue l'étude
chinoise n'est absolument pas
transposable à 7 à cette situation
emmanuel macron s'exprime donc ce soir
il devrait annoncer un allègement des
restrictions comment selon vous est-ce
qu'on peut réussir ce déconfinement et
bien simplement en allégeant mais pas en
supprimant c'est à dire je pense que
lille et il est absolument fondamental
que tout le monde est bien prêt
à l'esprit que notre protection à tous
dépend de notre attitude à tous c'est à
dire que chacun d'entre nous est
susceptible de transmettre le virus si
on le porte et parfois on ne sait pas
quand le porte de le transmettre à notre
voisin à notre famille et ça c'est pas
un gouvernement qu'il fait à votre place
c'est chacun d'entre nous qui doit se
prendre en main et continuer à respecter
un minimum de protection des autres la
responsabilité individuelle mais quelle
mesure attendez-vous de l'allocution ce
soir d'emmanuel macro est ce qu'il faut
que le déconfinement passe par un
déconfinement par région par un
couvre-feu très concrètement quelles
mesures seraient l'ailé les plus
pertinentes selon vous il y en a pas qui
soient plus pertinente qu'une autre que
c'est simplement le principe c'est
d'éviter le contact entre des gens
porteurs et des jambes au secteur ça
c'est le principe de base alors qu'à
isoler les malades on évoque notamment
l'idée de rendre obligatoires les
analyses le monde et des personnes
dépistées positives au kovy 19 rendent
obligatoire obligatoire c'est joli c'est
déjà la recommandation on dit pas aux
malades d'aller se promener dans les
dans les grandes surfaces
donc ça c'est absolument évident mais
rendre obligatoire ça veut dire qu'elle
un contrôle
alors comment on contrôle c'est donc là
d'une question là l'enjeu de cette
possible isolement des malades
il est aussi question des dépistages des
tests antigénique ils seront primordiaux
dans cette
bon ce deuxième déconfinement j'en suis
pas sûr je suis pas sûr du tout parce
que quand on quand on fait un dépistage
il faut qu'ils aient un objectif
derrière c'est pas juste pour avoir un
résultat qu'on met dans la poche et on
fait plus rien c'est parce qu'il ya
quelque chose derrière le quelque chose
en question c'est effectivement une
recommandation de d'isolement et les
suivis et n'est pas suivie jusque là et
n'est pas bien suivi
c'est clair on le voit au quotidien les
mesures qu'on préconise sont peu
respectés la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'on n'a eu la deuxième vague si les
mesures avaient été respectées on
n'aurait pas eu donc ça s'éteint c'est
un point essentiel le deuxième point
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que le
test il ne donne un résultat que pour
l'instant où vous avez fait le test
c'est à dire que deux heures après vous
pouvez vous contaminer donc l'utilité du
dépistage aveugle très sincèrement j'y
crois pas merci pour votre réaction jean
paul stahl infectiologues au chu de
grenoble alpes